انضموا الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك حضره اللواء
ما ابرز ما يلفت الانتباه في هذه الاخبار
انصحت طبعا من شبكه سي ان ان
يعني تقريبا الاستراتيجيه الرئيسيه في
الصناعات العسكريه الايرانيه هي تعتمد
الهندسه العسكريه
العكسيه
وبالتالي كافه الصواريخ دون استثناء وانت
ذكرت صاروخ طوفان صواريخ الباريستيه
وصواريخ ضد البحر
وصواريخ ضد الدرع وحتى دبابه كرار
جميعها اعتمدت مقاربه الهندسه العسكريه
العكسيه لان هذا هذا النوع مسموح به من
قبل كثير من الدول ولا يعتبر مخالف
قانونيا الا من قبل بعض الدول الاوروبيه
وهذا يقدم الكثير من اهمها يساعد على
الابتكار
كنا نتحدث عن اهميه ما ورد في
ما ذكرته سينام ولكن توقفت عند اشارتك
للهندسه العكسيه لو تشرح لنا ما معنى
الهندسه العكسيه
يا سيدي الهندسه العكسيه هي عباره عن
الوصول من خلال تحليل البيانات
وتفكيك اليات او قطع تصنيع
سلاح معين والوصول الى القواعد الناظمه
لصناعته وتجميعه وتوظيفه واستخدامه والان
عند اعتماد الهندسه العسكريه العكسيه
اصبحت نوع من الاستراتيجيه لدى العديد من
الدول ومن اهمها تركيا ايران البرازيل
الهند باكستان وحتى مصر جميعها تعتمدها
ولان القانون لا تعتبر مخالفه ولا تعتبر
عمليه اقتباس انت تحلل هذه المنظومه صاروخ
جافلين مكوناته التقنيات الموجوده به
وتعمل محاكاه له فانت توفر مبالغ كثيره من
المال
تخصص لاغ بحث والتطوير تمكنك من اكتشاف
نقاط الضعف والاخطاء وتجاوزها في تصنيعك
نعود الى ايران تحديدا كافه الصواريخ
الباليستيه وصواريخ ضد الدرع وصواريخ ضد
القطع البحريه
مطوره عن اما صناعه صينيه او صناعه روسيه
او صناعه كوريه حتى دبابه كرار هي صناعه
عسكريه عكسيه عن دبابه تي 9 تي شكرا
وبالتالي اذا ما
هذه المعدات تحديدا في جمله واحده جافل
استنكر صواريخ ضد الدرع وصواريخ ضد الجو
ستكون تشكل قفز نوعيه شو تطور الصناعات
العسكريه الايرانيه شكرا لك لوفي من عمان